YOU TODAY ON THE DIRE- WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PARTY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I TASHA BOERNER HORVATH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH MISSING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS WITH US.
WE WILL ALSO BE JOINED BY TONY
SIMONS OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT OF
THE ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS CHEN AGAIN THE
CONSULTANT FOR THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS POLICY UNIT. JOINING US
FROM THE COMMITTEE OFFICES
MERCEDES FLORES THE COMMITTEE
SECRETARY FOR THE ASSEMBLY JOBS
COMMITTEE IF THERE ARE ANY
TECHNICAL ISSUES A MERCEDES IS
AVAILABLE TO ASSIST YOU AND SHE
CAN BE REACHED AT 916-319-2090
TODAY WE WILL BE ADOPTING
COMMITTEE ROLLS AND THEN
HEARING FIVE BILLS ARE
INCLUDING AB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN AB ELEVEN FORTY SIX AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY ONE. AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY TWO AND AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. WE WILL ALSO
REVIEW THREE BILLS ON CONSENT
AND THAT IS AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
ONE FIFTEEN SEVENTY TWO IN
FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. MEMBERS I
DO WANT TO ADD TO KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SUPPLEMENTAL- THE
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. YOUR
SEATS TODAY. BEFORE WE DO BEGIN
OUR BILL PRESENTATION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN I NEED
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF TO
THE PUBLIC. ON HOW THEY CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THIS MORNING'S
HEARING DUE TO THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE ARE
PARTICIPATING- PHYSICALLY
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING THIS MEANS WE
ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCHING
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. WE ARE ALSO REQUIRED THAT
MUST BE WORN IN PHYSICAL
DISTANCE BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS. OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. WE DO HAVE A FEW
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. FOR REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS IF ANYONE IS USING
THIS OPTION IN ADDITION TO
BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM WE HAVE
SOME BILL WITNESSES WHO MAY BE
MAKING IT USE OF ONE OF OUR
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS WHICH
ARE LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM AND ALSO ASK THEM
QUESTIONS DIRECTLY. FOR DIAL IN
WITNESSES SO WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING ROOM.
IS. 877-692-8957 IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. THIS IS ALSO ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU ARE
CALLING AND PLEASE PLAN TO DO
SO AT THE BEGINNING OF A BILL
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. YOU MAY BE
ASKED BY THE MODERATOR TO
IDENTIFY WHETHER YOU'LL BE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. IF
YOU'RE CALLING PLEASE. TRY YOUR
BEST TO LEMONADE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MEETING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU
ARE- IN YOUR MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY TODAY FOR
OR AGAINST A BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON THE LIVE LINE- IN
WILL NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF.
UNTIL YOUR CALL TO SPEAK ON.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COOPERATION
AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS. WE ARE
ALL FACED WITH. SO MEMBERS
BEFORE WE BEGAN- TODAY'S HE
FILE ITEMS ON FILE I LIKE TO
JUST ACKNOWLEDGE. THAT IT'S WE
HAVE EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS I TO COMMITTEE AND
FOR PROCEEDINGS ARE CONDUCTS
THAT DESTRUCT OR DISTURB
OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. THE RULES FOR
TODAY'S HEARING INCLUDE WEARING
A MASK OVER YOUR MOUTH NOSE AT
ALL TIMES AND COMPLYING WITH
PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEEN. NO
TALKING OR LONG NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE
PROVIDED ONLY AT THE DESIGNATED
TIME AND PLACE AS PERMITTED BY
THE CHAIR. PUBLIC COMMENT MUST
RELATE TO THE SUBJECT OR BILLS
BEING DISCUSSED TODAY AND NO
ENGAGING IN CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS
HEARING PLEASE BE AWARE THAT
ANY VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES
MAY BE SUBJECT TO REMOVAL OR
OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COOPERATION. SO WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM WITH US IT
WILL BE A FREE WILL BE A CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL ROLE SO
WE CAN FORMALLY ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SHARE CERVANTES HERE
SHARES OF ARTISTS HERE THANKS
CARE CUNNINGHAM. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BORDER HARD OUT
HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TRAVEL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATRICK NORRIS.
ASSEMBLY PET YOUR NORTH HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. ASSEMBLY
RAR ROBLOX HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH HERE. MADAM CHAIR YOU
HAVE A QUORUM. SO NOW THAT
WE'VE ESTABLISHED REQUIREMENTS
LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN A
REGULAR ORDER BUSINESS I LIKE
TO FIRST ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
ROLES I BELIEVE EVERYONE HAS A
COPY AT THEIR DESK I SHOULD ANY
MEMBER. ARE THE OF THEM
ACTUALLY TO START DO I HAVE A
MOTION. AND A SECOND. SO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH AND MOVED A SECOND
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS. WELL
THE CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY
ARCHITECTURE CERVANTES I
CERVANTES HI ASSEMBLY VICE
CHAIR CUNNINGHAM. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER TRAVEL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATRICK NORRIS
HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
DELIVER RAMOS HI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH HI. WHO WAS THE DIRECTOR
THAT ON CALL YES THANK YOU SO
WHO ARE WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
MEMBERS WHO ARE ABSENT AT THE
MOMENT WE WILL PUT THAT BILL OR
THAT- THIS COMMITTEE MOMENTS.
ON COST LET ME GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO OUR FIRST ITEM TODAY
WILL BE HEARING A. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN RELATING TO THE
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BANK IN
HOUSING. BEFORE WE ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PULLED INTO
BEGAN HIS PRESENTATION AGAIN
THE NUMBER TO CALL LINDA I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTIFY THE PUBLIC
IS. 877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN WHEN YOU
ARE READY TO BEGIN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN TO THE COMMITTEE THIS
MORNING. I FIRST LIKE TO STATE
THAT I WILL BE ACCEPTING
AMENDMENT BE REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS WHICH IS REQUIRING THE
HOUSING TO BE INCIDENTAL TO THE
PROJECT DEFINED AS 20% OR LESS
OF THE PROJECT COST. I WILL
ALSO COMMIT TO WORKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS A
AMENDMENT HEY. WHICH IS THE
AMENDMENT REFLECTING MAKE OTHER
TECHNICAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES. AFTER THE EXCLUSION OF
THE AYE SIR ALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING YES.
THERE WE ARE. SO JUST TO BE
CLEAR- IT WOULD BE- WHAT IT TOO
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE AN EXACT
NUMBER IT WAS NOT INCLUDED ON
THAT- THE MOCK UP BECAUSE YOU
WOULD BE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON IT- AND THE AT
COMMITMENT WAS TO WORK ON THE
EXCLUSION OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING AT THE I THINK IT'S
CALLED THE AYE SIR PROGRAM. AND
THAT WOULD BE A DISCUSSION THAT
WOULD BE ONGOING FOR THE
COMMITTEE CORRECT. THANK YOU.
AB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN WILL
CLARIFY THE I. BANK. MAY
FINANCE HOUSING AS A PART OF AN
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE PROJECT ONLY
WHEN THE HOUSING ELEMENT IS
REQUIRED FOR THE OPERATION OF
THE PROJECT. ADDITIONALLY NO
PART OF THE HOUSING ELEMENT CAN
BE ROOF WE CAN BE FINANCED.
WITH TAX EXEMPT BONDS TO ENSURE
THERE IS NO CONFLICT WITH OTHER
STATE. HOUSING FINANCE
PROGRAMS. UNDER CURRENT LAW HI
BANK IS AUTHORIZED TO FINANCE A
WIDE VARIETY OF PUBLIC AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS.
BUT EXPRESSLY EXCLUDES HOUSING
WITHOUT DEFINING THE SCOPE. OF
THAT RESTRICTION OR CLEAR
INDICATION WHY. JOSELU
PROHIBITION ON HOUSING AND I
BANK ACT CREATES A FINANCING
GAP BY EXCLUDING ALL PROJECTS
TO CONTAIN ANY ELEMENTS OF
HOUSING. FOR EXAMPLE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE FACULTY HOUSING FOR
SCHOOLS GROUNDSKEEPERS OR
OPERATORS FACILITIES SUMMER AND
USE CAPS AND TREATMENT RELATED
HOUSING FOR SOCIAL SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS COULD NOT BE
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN THESE
PROJECTS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE. AS
A FINANCER OF LAST RESORT FOR
MANY PROJECTS THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW AYE BANKS TO ADD AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN THE IN THE
STATE'S TOOLBOX TO INCREASE
MORE TARGETED AND CREATIVE
APPROACHES TO HOUSING. TODAY I
HAVE WITH ME EMBERT MADISON
FROM THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
I THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR LOCAL. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN FOR
ACCEPTING- THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. LET ME GO AHEAD AND
ASK THE MODERATOR I UNDERSTAND
WE HAVE MISTER AMBER MADISON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION ON THE CONFERENCE
LINE MISTER MADISON YOU CAN
BEGIN. THANK YOU MR HOLDER FOR
INTRODUCING BILL. AS INTRODUCED
PREVIOUSLY STATED MY NAME IS
AMBER MADISON AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION CA AS
WE'RE NOT A SHORTHAND IS THE
LARGEST RENTAL HOUSING TRADE
ASSOCIATION IN THE COUNTRY. WE
REPRESENT OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
SINGLE FAMILY AND MULTI FAMILY
APARTMENT OWNERS AND PROPERTY
MANAGERS. WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVER TWO MILLION AFFORDABLE AND
MARKET RATE UNITS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
THINK. THE I MAKE ACT PROVIDED
A CRUCIAL FINANCING MECHANISM
FOR PUBLIC DEVELOPMENT
FACILITIES THAT SOMETIMES
INCLUDE AN ELEMENT OF HOUSING.
AB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN THE
TYPICALLY PROVIDES OF THESE
PROJECTS THAT INCLUDE HOUSING
AND THE REQUIRED ELEMENTS. FOR
PROJECT OPERATION CAN YOU
TACTIC THAT BONDS THE LONGER
THE HOUSING PORTION IF NOT
FINANCED BY THOSE BONDS.
APPLICATION WILL HAVE THE
EFFECT OF MOVING PROJECTS ALONG
THAT WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN
PROHIBITED. THE AB TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN WILL INCREASE
HOUSING SUPPLY BY ALLOWING
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. THAT
COULD INCLUDE HOUSING TO BE
FINANCED UNDER THE IBENIK. FOR
THOSE REASONS AND ON BEHALF OF
CA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
MATTIS SAID THAT LET ME GO
AHEAD AND ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL SARGENT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION SAYING THAT THERE IS
NOT. A MISTER MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ELSE ON THE CONFERENCE
LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO. SPEAK
WITH. BILL PLEASE PRESS.
ONE
WHAT IS HERE ARE FROM THE
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
IT ARE THERE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION OR MODERATOR
ON THE CONFERENCE SIGNED IT
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE EXCUSE ME UP I LOST
CONNECTION PER SECOND. I AM
BACK- AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME THANK YOU. WE
COULD TAKE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
MODERATOR ATTITUDE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN. OKAY REAL GOOD I MY
LOOK MIND DISCONNECTED FOR
SECOND THANK YOU AND I TO SHOW
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND MADAM CHAIR NOBODY
IS GIVING UP. SO MEMBERS AND
NOW AT THIS TIME- WE CAN MOVE
TO DISCUSSION OR ANY QUESTIONS
JIM ANY MEMBERS WISH TO. ASK
QUESTIONS OR DO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. SECOND WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SOMEBODY
MEMBER ALMOST IN A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN DO YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE CLOSING AND CLOSING
STATEMENTS- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THE BILL
AND FOR THE STAFF'S ANALYSIS
AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AYE BANK ON
CREATING THIS ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY TO FURTHER ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. PROJECTS WERE
HOUSING IN A SENSE ANCILLARY
PART OF IT SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU MR
HOLDER AND WE CERTAINLY LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH YOU ON. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE- FUND PLAN AND
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL TO- THE LEGISLATURE THE
MOTION ON AB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN IS DUE PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT WELL THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
CERVANTES I HEAR CERVANTES BY
BY SECURE CUNNINGHAM BUT YOU'RE
CUNNINGHAM HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH HI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHILD BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATRICK NORRIS ASSEMBLY PETRIE
NORRIS HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS. DELIVER RAMOS HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SPENT. SEVEN
MEMBER SMITH HI. MEMBERS ON A
SEVEN TWO ZERO VOTE AB TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN IS OUT. THANK
GOODNESS THAT OLDER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A LET US MOVE TO THE
NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA.
ACTUALLY NOW THAT WE DO HAVE
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WHO SHALL WE
LIFT THE CALL ON THE CONSENT-
THE COMMITTEE ROLES. AND ALLOW
MEMBERS OUT ON. THIS IS ITEM
ONE IT IS ADOPTION OF THE
COMMITTEE RULES- I AM ONLY
GOING TO MEANT THAT NOT
MENTIONING THE MEMBERS WERE NOT
ON FALL ARE NOT ON THE ROLE OF
THE MOMENT. THANKS FOR
CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOUR
CUNNINGHAM HI. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TRAVEL. SOBRE CALLE HI. MEMBERS
ON A VOTE OF SEVEN TO ZERO THE
CLEAR RULES ARE ADOPTED. VICE
CHAIR CUNNINGHAM ASK YOU TO TRY
THE HEARING Y. PRESENT MY TWO
BILLS THANK YOU. I'VE BEEN
THREE FOUR THAT'S ON PAGE TEN.
YEAH.
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS NEXT WE WILL BE SHARING
ITEM THREE WHICH IS AB ELEVEN
FORTY SIX BY CHAIR CERVANTES
RELATING TO THE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMERCIAL RENT FORGIVENESS AND
TAX RELIEF ISSUE- BEFORE SHE
BEGINS HER PRESENTATION ON AB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX LET ME GIVE
EVERYONE NOTICED THAT THE PHONE
LINES ARE OPEN FOR WITNESSES TO
GET IN THE QUEUE. CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE. ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN- MANAGER
UNDERSTAND TO BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED IN THE
BILL ANALYSIS UNDER COMMENT
SEVEN. YES I'LL BE EXPECTING
THE AMENDMENT SO NOTED THANK
YOU THEY'RE ALSO COPIES EACH
MEMBERS CHAIR. ON THE TABLE
OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM AND ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SEASON UNSERVED
ADOPTED AND YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- I DO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE MOMENTS
WITH SOUND COMMON SEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS AB ELEVEN FORTY SIX
AUTHORIZES THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA REP FORGIVENESS
AND TAX RELIEF PROGRAM. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PROVIDING GRANTS TO
QUALIFIED COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT
LOCAL RENT FORGIVENESS AND TAX
RELIEF PROGRAMS. AS CALIFORNIA
TRANSITIONS OUT OF THE PANDEMIC
AND RETAIL STORES AND
RESTAURANTS TO REOPEN. THESE
TEMPORARY PROTECTIONS WILL
EXPIRE AND DEFERRED RENTS WILL
BECOME DO. LANDLORDS HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM SEVERAL OTHER
FEDERAL DISASTER PROGRAMS AND
LACKING FULL RENT PAYMENTS AS
INCOME MANY LANDLORDS HAVE
FACED THEIR OWN DIFFICULTY AND
PAYMENT OF PROPERTY TAXES
UTILITIES. AND OTHER
MAINTENANCE COSTS WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE INTERVENTION
CALIFORNIA MAY NOT HAVE THE RE
OPENING THAT IS REQUIRED FOR A
SUCCESSFUL AND INCLUSIVE
RECOVERY. WITH ME TODAY ARE
NUMBER WITNESSES TO TALK ABOUT
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL
INCLUDING MATTHEW HARGROVE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION AND MARK
HERBERT WITH THE SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA. MISTER MODERATOR
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE MISTER
HARGROVE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
ON THE ONFERENCE LINE MISTER
GROVE YOU CAN BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. MRARE BROKERS GO AHEAD
NOT MEET YOUR PHONE. TWENTY
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION.
CAN YOU HARASSMENT RIGHT NOW
YES YES I'M HERE I AM A NEW DID.
MISTER HARGROVE BEGAN WHEN
READY. CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW. YES.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE MAP YOU ARE GOOD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION I REALLY
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
MOVING FORWARD THIS BILL- THE
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN ROUGH ON
EVERYBODY AS WE ALL KNOW- THE
ECONOMIC SHUT DOWN IN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY HARD ON SOME OF
THE SMALLER BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE MANY OF THE PROPERTY
OWNERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HAVE WORKED VERY HARD TO KEEP
THEIR TENANTS WITHIN THEIR
SPACES. THERE IS NO INCENTIVE
FOR A PROPERTY OWNER ON THE
COMMERCIAL SIDE TO TRY AND MOVE
A TENANTS OUT OF THEIR SPACE
RIGHT NOW- THERE'S NOT A HUGE
LINE OF PEOPLE COMING IN AND
THERE'S A SYMBIOTIC
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
COMMERCIAL AND THE- THAT
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS HOWEVER
THERE ARE SOME VERY SMALL
COMPANIES THAT EVEN WITHOUT
ASSISTANCE OR THEY MIGHT BE IN
A PROPERTY WHERE THEY'RE NOT
GETTING SOME HELP FROM THE
LANDLORD. WHERE PROGRAMS LIKE
THIS I WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL
VERY APPRECIATED WE VERY MUCH
LIKE THE CONCEPTS WITHIN AB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX THIS IS VERY
MUCH LIKE THE RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAM THAT WAS VOTED ON AND
PASSED EARLIER THIS YEAR AND
LAST YEAR AND THAT IT HAPPENED
FUNDING BEHIND IT IT WOULD
DIRECTLY HELP LANDLORDS WHO ARE
WORKING WITH THEIR TENANTS TO
DO THINK THAT A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS WILL BE HELPFUL TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE PULLED OUT OF THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. FOR THOSE REASONS AND
FOR WHAT THE AUTHORS STATED IN
HER OPENING STATEMENT WE'RE
HAPPY HAPPY TO BE HERE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS BILL
AND HOPE. THAT YOU PASSAGE OF
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MISS MODERATOR- SO
WITNESS IN THE QUEUE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
YEP THERE IS A SECOND WITNESS
GO AHEAD AND- UNMUTE YOURSELF
YOU'RE LYING TO BE OPEN IF YOU
ARE A WITNESS. SPEND MORNING
AND THIS IS NOT MARKED. AS MY
NAME IS BIANCA MARKETS MY BY- I
NINETEEN YEAR POLICY MANAGER
FOR SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY-
AND I WANT I THINK THE
CHAIRWOMAN AT THEIR CONTENT THE
MEMBERS OF THE STUDY COMMITTEE
FOR. ALLOWING US BECOME THE
SUPER IMPORTANT ISSUE THIS
MORNING. SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY IS AND NATIONAL SMALL
BUSINESS ORGANIZATION AND WE
EMPOWER I AMERICANS BY BIRTH
ENTREPRENEURS AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA'S ENTREPRENEURS- AND
ENGAGE OUR NETWORK OF MORE THAN
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ADVOCATE ADVOCATE
FOR PUBLIC POLICY SOLUTION. ON
AND DELIVER THESE RESOURCES TO
THE. ENTREPRENEURS THAT NEED
THEM THE MOUNT. I OUR DEEP CAN
I WITH THE MOB COMMUNITY- ALONG
OUR- RESEARCH ENABLE US TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ABOUT KEY
ISSUES OR LIKE THAT ONE. OUR
MOST RECENT SURVEY THAT RELIEF
TO BE FORTHCOMING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH SOME OTHER
NONPROFIT PARTNERS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED. THAT 80% OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO RAN FOR-
OWN COMMERCIAL FAITH THAT THIS
TIME ARE STRUGGLING WITH
PAYMENTS. MORE THAN HALF ARE
SAYING THAT THERE ARE MULTIPLE
MONTHS BEHIND ON THEIR RENT OR
MORTGAGE 20% OF SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS THE BRAND- OR OWN THEIR
COMMERCIAL SPACE HAVE BEEN
THREATENED WITH EVICTION. I
ADDITIONALLY ARE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORT
PUBLIC POLICY SALUTE SOLUTION
TO HELP THOSE THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO PAY FOR
COMMERCIAL RENT. OUR NETWORK
ACTUALLY SHOWS THAT 71% NOT
BUSINESS OWNER AT THE PORT
PUBLIC THE PUBLIC POLICY
SOLUTIONS LIKE THIS ONE. IN
SUMMARY WE BELIEVE THAT. I ANY
RELIEF PROVIDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. MAGIC MALL
BUSINESS OWNERS MUST BE TIED
SUPPORTING AND SAVING THE
FOLKS. WE I'M MUST ADDRESS THE
BLEAK OUTLOOK FOR COMMERCIAL
VENTURES THAT THE TIMING THAT
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
CHAIRMAN AND HER AMAZING STAFF
ON AT ELEVEN FORTY SIX AND WE
ALSO EXTEND OUR THANKS TO
GENEROUS. WOMAN CERVANTES FOUR
I YOUR LEADERSHIP AND IN
SUPPORTING MY MOTHER'S NOT
HONOR. ANYTHING A POTENTIAL
WINDFALL OF PASSED THE RENTAL
PAYMENT ACROSS. CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME AND IN THE ROOM SEE IF WAS
TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF THE BILL
SAYING NO ONE WILL MOVE TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION NOPE.
SELECT THERE'S NO ONE THERE. I
BELIEVE THAN. MISTER MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ELSE ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN ON THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
IN THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
OPERATORS GOING TO GIVE RELY
NUMBER OFFLINE. IN A PLACE YOU
BACK INTO THE QUEUE. SO AGAIN
GO AHEAD HIT ONE ZERO TO PLACE
YOURSELF. INTO THE QUEUE. BOB
WHITE SIXTEEN I THINK YOU TOOK
YOURSELF OUT THANK YOU FOR PUT
OKAY. YOUR BACK WILL GO AHEAD
AND OPEN UP LINE SIXTEEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANKS SORRY
ABOUT SORRY ABOUT THAT I'M
STILL KIND OF THE SPIES AND
THIS IS KAREN LANE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY TREASURERS AND TAX
COLLECTORS. MADAM CHAIR AND MR
I'M SORRY JERRY WANTED TO
PERFECT THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
CONSULTANT HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
SPECTACULAR THAT WORKS TO THE
CONCERN THAT THE COUNTY TAX
COLLECTOR TOD WITH THE FIRST
VERSION OF THE BALLOT. AND I
WANT TO SAY AT THE OUTSET.
ABSOLUTELY NO OBJECTION TO WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH-
THE SAME THING HERE YOU'RE
WORRIED ABOUT MORE WORRIED
ABOUT AND- ON- UNPAID RENT.
WHEN THEY'RE TENANTS WERE
CLOSED AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE LEARNED. THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC AND THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER RELATED TO PROPERTY TAX
PAYMENTS IS THAT BECAUSE IT WAS
HAPPENNG SORT OF IN REAL TIME
THERE WERE DIFFERENCES AND THE
APPLICABILITY OF THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER. FIFTY COUNTY IS NOT BY
ANYBODY'S- ABOUT INTENT IT WAS
JUST THAT WE WERE DOING WHAT WE
CAN WITH WHAT WE HAD. AS IT WAS
COMING THROUGH I'M SO WHAT WE
WHAT WE ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
TO DEAL WITH THE DELL IS MAKE
SURE THAT THE- APPLICATIONS IN
ELIGIBILITY ELIGIBILITY OR
ACTUALLY PROCESS AT THE STATE
LEVEL. AND WE WANT OUT BECAUSE
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES ARE
PARTICIPATING. AND BUSINESSES
IN SMALLER COUNTIES OR COUNTIES
THAT DON'T HAVE THE TECHNICAL A
SET UP THROUGH THE PROCESS THE
APPLICATION TIMELY AND
ACCURATELY BUT THE RIGHT DATA
MANAGEMENT- AREN'T
DISADVANTAGED BECAUSE THEY ARE
IN THE COUNTY THAT DOESN'T HAVE
THOSE RESOURCES CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE. THE VERSION OF THE
BILL IN FRONT OF YOU DOESN'T
DIRECTLY INCLUDE THE TAX
COLLECTOR ANYMORE IT DOES
REQUIRE COUNTY BY INDO AND WITH
THE FACT THAT THAT WOULD
INVOLVE ALTERNATELY. THE TAX
COLLECTORS OF THERE'S THE TAX
PIECE OF IT SO WE WAITED AND
OTHER ON THE FIFTH GAS. UNTIL A
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED THE
POCKET WITH PROGRAM FOR SENIORS
IN THE- ON THE CONTROLLER DONE
A- FANTASTIC JOB PRO IT'S A
VERY WELL RUN. AND WE WOULD WE
KNOW HOW TO YOU KNOW HOW WORK
WITH THE- ON THAT KIND OF ALL.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD
LOOK AT. BUT WE DO NOT WANT TO
STAY IN THE WAY WHAT THE AND
THE COMING TRYING TO CALM THAT
JUST. ACQUIRE MORE DEFENDER
TENANTS BE OPEN. AND WE OPEN
SIX IN AND CAL RECOVER. THE
STAFF IS POSSIBLE FROM WHAT
TYPE AGAINST YOU WE ARE. STILL
PENDING READY TO HOWEVER WE CAN.
AND WE'RE NOT DOING IT JUST
BECAUSE- MARKET IS IN A NOT
JUST THAT WE DON'T. DO THE WORK
FOR REALLY WORRIED CAPACITY.
AND- TO. ACROSS ALL FIFTY SO
AGAINST THE YOU WERE
TECHNICALLY NEUTRAL BUT.
THERE'S A WHAT OF SUPPORT FOR
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH. AND WE TO BE A-
CONTRACT. SO HOW DO FOR THE
RAMBLING COMMON BUT THEY WERE
IN PART TO OUR- MEMBERS TO THE
COMMITTEE. THAT TIME THAT WE DO
WANNA BE HEALTH TO YOU. AND WE
WANT TO HELP OUR- THE
CONTROLLERS OFF THE DOCTOR THEY
CAN BE WANTS CAL. THANK YOU SO
FOR CONSIDERING THANK. AND
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND TO
SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY THE ZERO. ONE FILED BY. ZERO
MR SURE NOBODY'S QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR- MEMBERS IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. MR
BOERNER HORVATH YEAH I WANT TO
SAY THIS IS AN AMAZING. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
FORWARD- BUT THE OTHER. AND
WITH THAT I MOVED. IT MOVE MS
BOERNER HORVATH SAT BY MR. AND
CLOSING STATEMENT. I RESPECT
ASK FOR I- WILL BE SURE TO OUT
TO I BELIEVE IT SINCE IT IS A
COMMITTED ON MEMBER ARE-
ACTUALLY I. A FAIR BILL. SMALL
OAKS IS ME I'M THE I'M SKIPPING
TO THE NEXT OF. YES YES IS A
YOU WILL BE AT I DO NOT MEMBER
WISH TO ADDED AS CO AUTHOR
ANIKA I DO A TO JUST- AND THIS
THAT THE IS AN OPTION PROGRAM-
THAT NEITHER COUNTY NOR THE
LINE. OR TO APPLY LISTENING.
AROUND PEOPLE DISCUSSION THAT
WE'VE HAD A FOR OVER A YEAR NOW
THIS ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUES WAS BROUGHT HER TEN
WHICH IS WHY. I USED TO THIS
BEFORE IT FIRST I FOR I'VE.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE CLOSE
REMARKS I TO LIKE TO BE AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE APPROPRIATE-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AVIELLE
FORTY SIX THE MOTION IS DEEP.
WITH TO. WENT SHARES OF OUR- I.
CERVANTES I VICE CHAIR
CUNNINGHAM HI BUT YOU'RE
CUTTING I. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERNARD. HI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CAL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER OUT
HI. A SIMILAR PICTURE NORRIS
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER PICKED
NORRIS HI SOMEONE ROCKY. SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AT THAT RAMOS
HI SUMMER SPENT. I'D LIKE TO BE
A VISIBLE. TO ELEVEN FORTY SIX
IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS WE NOW
MOVE TO ITEM FOUR AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY ONE BY A CHAIR
CERVANTES RELATING TO THE SMALL
BUSINESS REGULATORY FAIRNESS
ISSUE DURING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY BEFORE THE JURY BEGAN
SIR PRESENTATION ON FIFTEEN
SEVENTY ONE- AGAIN I'M REQUIRED
TO GIVE NOTICE THAT THE PHONE
LINES ARE OPEN FOR WITNESSES TO
GET IN THE QUEUE. THE CALLING
NUMBER AGAIN IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. A MANAGER YOU MAY BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPERS FINANCE
PROFESSIONALS AND EVEN THE
OFFICE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYSTS AGREE THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY IMPACTED BY THE
CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC. AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY ONE A COMMITTEE
BILL DELIVERS REGULATORY RELIEF
TO SMALL BUSINESSES DURING A
STATE OF EMERGENCY. BY EITHER
EXEMPTING SMALL BUSINESSES FROM
COMPLIANCE UNTIL AFTER THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY OR IN THE
CASE THAT REGULATION IS
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THE
EMERGENCY OR SERIOUS AND
IMMEDIATE HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUE. PROVIDING SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH SUFFICIENT TIME
TO LEARN ABOUT AND IMPLEMENT
ANY NEW REGULATION. ONE
ESTIMATE IS THAT MORE THAN
NINETEEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
PERMANENTLY CLOSED IN
CALIFORNIA. MANY OF WHICH WERE
OWNED BY WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
TAKE CONCRETE STEPS TO SUPPORT
SMALL BUSINESSES DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND THIS IS LIMITING
NEW REGULATIONS TO ONLY THOSE
THAT ARE MOST UNNECESSARY. IN
THE CASE WERE NEW REGULATIONS
ARE NECESSARY AGENCIES THAT
NEED TO BE REALISTIC ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES SMALL BUSINESSES
FACE. DURING EMERGENCY AGENCIES
SHOULD CONSIDER ALTERNATIVE
OUTREACH METHODS FACILITATING
GROUP PURCHASING OR OF SCARCE
PRODUCTS AND FUNDING SMALL
BUSINESS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE.
IN A DECLARED SAY OF A
GOVERNMENT ROLE MAKING SHOULD
NOT BE KIND- CONDUCTED IN A
SMALL IN A BUSINESS AS USUAL
MANNER. SO WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS MISTER PHILIP REMOVE ONE.
REPRESENTING THE COALITION FOR
SMALL BUSINESS AND DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS AND PLEASURE
BARRICADE ASSOCIATION. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MR MODERATOR
IS- MR VERMEULEN READY TO
TESTIFY ON THE CONFERENCE LINE.
INDEED PLEASE GO AHEAD MR
BERMAN. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ON SILVER MEAL
AND REPRESENTING THE COALITION
OF SMALL DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESSES THE FLAGSHIP CARE
KID. AND I ALSO SIT ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES-
SMALL BUSINESS ADVISORY TASK
FORCE- I'VE BEEN REPRESENTING
SMALL BUSINESS FOR OVER FORTY
SEVEN YEARS- IN THE CAPITAL
AND- DELTA CONSIDERED WITH
GREAT. WRAPPING YEARS AND EVEN
IN NORMAL TIME- A LOT THESE
REGULATIONS PASS. BUT THE
NUMBER OF THE PROPERLY OUT- THE
P. THAT ARE AFFECTED BY THEM
COULD A LOT OF PROBLEM.
EXACERBATE THAT PROBLEM
SIGNIFICANTLY DUE TO THE COPD
OR ANY OTHER TYPE OF AN
EMERGENCY IT'S EVEN MUCH WORSE
OF THE SITUATION AND WE MUST BE
VERY. DURING THESE TIMES WHEN
THESE REGULATION ARE TRYING TO
VEHICLE THAT THE WILL COME OF
IMPACT THAT THEY HAVE ALL THESE
BUSINESS. THAT'S WHY WORK SO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE WE THAT IT
WILL GO A LONG WAY TOWARD THE
THESE FOR THOSE. I HEARD
COMMITTEE I THOUGHT THANK YOU.
FOR THANK YOU SIR MR. MISTER
NOW ON THE LINE TEST FOR IN
SUPPORT. MISTER MODERATOR IS
MISTER NELSON IN THE QUEUE FOR
ON THE LINE TO TEST YOU AND I
LOOK AT. I AM LOOKING FOR
MISTER NELSON I DO NOT SEE HIS
NAME. AS ONE OF THE SPEAKERS-
THE AT THAT IS CALLED ANALYTICS
WITH SOMEBODY ELSE. OKAY IS
THERE A SECOND WITNESS ON THE
LINE TO TEST FIND SUPPORTERS
FROM MAKE SURE NOT TO GIVE
ANYBODY. THERE'S A SECOND
WITNESS TO. TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE GO AHEAD
UNMUTE YOURSELF AT THIS TIME.
NOBODY IS UNYIELDING MISTER
CHAIR. OKAY WE CAN CIRCLE BACK
TO THAT. I'M NOT SEEING ANYBODY
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ON
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION IS
THE INDICATION SO I BELIEVE.
MISTER MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN
THE QUEUE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT AND TESTIFIED- IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT SIR AS WE
GET MISTER CHAIRS WE ARE GIVE
THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER. FOR
ANYBODY ELSE GOING AT ONE ZERO.
PUT YOURSELF IN Q. TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AND
WE'RE GONNA LINE IGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN MORNING
DAVE NOW BEEN THIRTY WITH
BLOCKED AND- IN THE COUNTRY-
THAT THEY PAULA POLICY CALPERS
ASIAN CHAMBER COMMERCE AND-
CALLING IN JUST A THIS. FOR ALL
THE READ THAT WAS TO THE- WE
STRONGLY URGE SUPPORT THE- IT'S
REALLY. THAT THE ROLE OF
BREAKING THAT DURING TIME IT
THAT MIGHT COURSE SMALL- AND SO.
WE ARE CALLING IN JUST FOR THE
BILL WILL ALSO BE SUPPORTING
THE TO BE ON THAT WILL BE- HER
PERFECT CURVES YOU AT THIS ONE
SO- POLITICS FOR THE DELAY IN
THE PHONE BUT ELEVATION CHANGE
STRONGLY SUPPORTS. AND URGES
THE PASSAGE THE. NO PROBLEM
THANK MISTER NO MISS MODERATE
IS OUR- IN QUEUE TO SPEAK
ENOUGH. IT'S GOOD TO OUR
SPEAKING UP TO THE BILL PLAY GO
AHEAD ONE FOR BY. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU AND SAYING NO
ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
NOBODY ON THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION WELL WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. WE WILL MOVE TO
DISCUSSION QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR. SEEING NONE WE WILL
MOVE TO. I BELIEVE THE BOOK
THOSE MOVE BONUS
BOERNER HORVATH IS THEIR SECOND.
SECONDED BY THE SPEECH NORRIS-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
PERSPECTIVE- ABOUT. PLEASE THE
MOTION ON AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
ONE IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW. IS THAT
CORRECT OKAY- PLEASE KALRA. AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY ONE- THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO ACCOUNTABILITY
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW- CHAIR
CERVANTES HI CERVANTES HI VICE
YOU'RE CUNNINGHAM I AM BY YOUR
CUNNINGHAM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HERVE FINE SO MEMBER WERNER HI
SOME CAL ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO OUT
I ASSEMBLY COUNTRY NORRIS HI
THIS AMERICAN NORTH HI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROB. DELIVER RAMOS HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH. SOME OF
MEMBERS I. MEMBERS ON A SUB TO
ZERO VOTE A FIFTY SEVENTY IS
OUT CONGRATS. AND WHAT THAT
WILL RETURN THE TO- CERVANTES.
THANK YOU TO OUR BY CHAIR I
MEMBERS WE NOT UP THE CONCERT
TO CARRY THERE'S A LIST OF
PROPOSED CONSENT ITEMS ON YOUR
AGENDA ON THE MEMBERS JUST SO
YOU HAVE A COPY OF TODAY THE
PROPOSED CONSENT ITEMS DO
INCLUDE AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY TWO
AND AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO HAVE
ANY OF THE MEASURES REMOVED
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
TODAY. C. NINE CAN I HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. OF A
MOTION BY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE
BOERNER HORVATH AND MOVED A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBERS. OUR
CAN I HAVE OR CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
THE AYE MOTION ON CONSENT THERE
ARE TWO ITEMS AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY TWO OF WHICH IS A DO
PASSED THE REVENUE AND TAX AND
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY FOUR WHICH
IS A DEEP PASS. TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE- REVIEW. SHARE
CERVANTES I TORONTO HI BUT
YOU'RE I THANK YOUR I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR. BOERNER HORVATH I'M
SORRY ABOUT MAKE IT MEMBER FOR
I SOME OF CHAD SO CHAD HI
ASSEMBLY PATRICK MORRIS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PET ARE I
MEMBER. SO THE RAMOS I SIMPLY
SPENT. I REMEMBER SMITH HI.
MEMBERS ON A SEVENTY YOUR VOTE
THE KIND CALENDAR OUR- THIS
DOES CONCLUDE BILL PRESENTATION
FOR THE DAY I WANT TO ASK HER
TO CONSULT TO SEE IF THERE ANY
TO CALL. ONE OF SCENERY ARE ALL
I ARE. SURE THIS COME TODAY
HEARING.